goo
6134名の方が亡くなった阪神淡路大震災
今年で20年が経ちました
私はその阪神淡路大震災がきっかけで今地震から人々を守る仕事をしています
普段は
企業や学校自治体さんなんかを相手に専門家として様々な減災に取り組んでいます
今日はその仕事の中で私がとても大切にしているアイディアのなかの一つを皆さんと
共有するためにここに来ました
テックス清水の開催地
この静岡は日本一地震に対する防災が進んでいる都市です
地震大国と呼ばれるこの日本ではどこでも大地震が起こります
では何故この静岡だけが進んでいる特別な街なのでしょうか
その理由は簡単です
日本一危険な場所はこの静岡だと
日本中がそう信じる出来事があったからです
今から39年前の昭和51年に
発表された駿河湾第二新設
汗にも最悪の大自身が静岡を襲うと日本中が大騒ぎし
国をあげてその対策をすることになったのです
しかし今ではその話もすっかり忘れられ
いつしか静岡の地震といえば
南海トラフ巨大地震へと変わってしまいました
南海トラフ巨大地震は
東日本大震災と同等のマグニチュード9クラスの地震が今度は西日本で起こるという話
です
みなさんここで気づいてほしいんですけども
いつのまにかもう戦う相手が変わっているということです
今目の前のスライドを見ていただくとこれが
今の皆さんが戦う相手です
39年前から皆さんが戦ってきた
戦おうとしてた相手がこの状態です
東海地震から南海トラフ巨大地震に呼び方が変わっただけではないんです
地震の規模も被害も
大幅に違う全く別の自信と戦わなければならないんです
皆さんが昔から訓練を重ねてきたのは4社
5851人という自信
それが今では静岡県内だけで死者10万9千人
という桁違いの自信に変わっているんです
この数字だと静岡県民の35人に1人が亡くなる計算になります
この会場にその数字を当てはめると約100人いらっしゃるこの会場では3人の方が
なくなります
どうぞ皆さんの周りでその32の方探してみてください
この書士にそうだなみたいな
これですねあのいつもこういう話をする時にあの必ず人の顔を見る人がいるんですね
自分は大丈夫だと
となりました女性だからこのサーブないんじゃないかなと
そういうようなあの目で見る人の方が危ないという話な
日本一危ないといわれ日本一防災に力を入れてきたのに
被害が減るどころか39年だって18倍になっているんです
何のために苦労して今まで備えできたのかよくわかんない
そんな話です
でも自然の力を相手にするということはそういうことなんです
昔も今も人間がどうこうできる力ではないんです
社会契約論で皆さんも一度は名前を聞いたことがある
哲学者ジャンジャックルソーは1755年に医師ヨーロッパ地方を襲った大獅子の経験
から
自然災害に対する教訓としてこんな言葉を残しています
自然は決して人間を欺かない
人間を欺くのは常に人間である
最大の災害は自らが招くものである
260年前のこのルソーの言葉はこんなに発達した今のこの世の中でも当てはまるん
です
20年前に起こった阪神淡路大震災では
自身が起こした大きな揺れによって
私たちの想像もできないことが起こり
被害が出ました
そして4年前の東日本大震災では
自身が起こした大きな津波によって
私たちの想像できないことが起こり
大きな被害が出ました
この2つの震災は全く違う地震によって起こったものですが
共通しているのは想像もできないことが起こった
つまり想定外だったということです
この想定外こそが被害を作るんです
想定は人が作るものです
人が作るもので被害が出るのであれば
それは防げる被害だということです
多くの尊い犠牲から私たちが学ぶべき真の教訓は
この想定外をなくすことなんです
とそれらしくん
行ってはみたものの100%人災であると言われている交通災害交通事故
どんなに頑張ったって交通事故でさえ
ゼロにできない私たちですから
自然災害を100%想定して防ぐということは不可能です
交通事故の話題が出たところでここねあなたに気づいてほしいことがもう一つあります
自己しそうならまずブレーキを踏め
そんな兵庫は聞いたことがありません
どんな事故かもわからないのにただブレーキを踏むだけで事故が防げるなんてそんな
話して
ありません
自身ではどうでしょうか
地震が来たら机の下にもぐれ地震が来たら頭を守れ
グラッときたら火を下せー
何が起こるか誰も分からないはずの地震で
自信だけはなぜか具体的に行動が決まってるんです
さらに日本の一番悪いところ一番いいところでもあるんですけども
何も考えなくても反射的に行えるレベルまで
さを磨いてしまっているということです
間違った教育を私たちは続けすぎたです
想定外を想像できなくなるようなこの教育は非常に危ないことなんです
なぜここまで一般常識化している地震教育を間違った教育と断言するのか
そこに私が皆さんと共有したいアイディアがあります
それを知って頂くためにここに一つの例を用意しました
地震が来たらあなたはどうしますか
会場の皆さんもこのスライダーを見ながらですね想像してください
地震が来たらあなたはどうしますか目の前に机がありますさああなたはどうしますか
おそらくこうするでしょ
ただ静岡の方にこのスライドを見せると静岡ではこうしないとよく怒られます
静岡ではこう
うーんってやっぱきますよね
これが高
ですねはい
私もこの状態であればつけま者にもぐれと
潜ります自分でも
これはあの素晴らしいことですね
机の下にもぐり机の足をすっかりつかむあなたここまでが私たちが今までやってきた
防災教育
次は
少し視野を広げてみます
シェアが少し広がりました救えとあなたしか見えていなかった
その状態からわずかちょっとこう見えてますけども
食器棚が倒れてこようとしています
このときあなたはどうしますか
私もこの状態であれば机の下に潜ります
これではどうでしょうか
食器棚その次がその上にある建物が倒れそう
あなたの家が倒れそうでも皆さんはしっかり
机の足を握っています
もう一つ
この状態どうでしょうか
隣のビルが倒れてきそう
実際に阪神淡路大震災でもあったことです
では次はどうでしょうか
いかにも津波が来そうな海が近い
でもあなたはしっかり机の下に潜って
足を握っているそこは変わらないんですね
このたった一つの例からもイメージが出来たと思うんですが
地震が来たらつ形の下にという
私たちが今まで行なってきた防災教育は正しいのでしょうか
間違っているのでしょうか
周りの状況から考えて机の下が安全であれば
も苦しい安全でなければ潜らない
正解があるとすればその時にならないとわからないです
このたった一つの例から
地震が来たらつけました理
という安易で断片的な教育を行ってはいけないということがわかっていただけたと思い
ます
皆さんが今まで受けてきた教育は間違っていたといえるのです
っつ
大事なのは地震への対応はいついかなる時も想像することを想像する力を身に付けて
おくことが大切なんです
私は今回のお話が会場の皆さん全員に響くものだとは残念ながら思っていません
しかし会場の皆さんに
必要な話であるという自信はあります
最大の災害は自らが招く不このルソーの言葉をぜひあなたの教訓にしてください
そう思うことがそうならないことへつながっていきます
一番悲しいことはあなたの間違った教育0
大切な誰かが知ることです
そうならないためにあなたが先生になってください
難しいことじゃないんです
2つのことだけ実行してください
想像がふくらむ教育創造教育をしてください
思いがます教育というふうに私たちは入ってます
もう一つ
想像を止めてしまう教育はしない
私たちが今まで習ってきたのは想像を止めてしまう教育です
それを今日覚えて帰ってください
繰り返しになりますが地震への対応は想像することが大切です
私はこれからもあらゆる手段を使って日本の現さに貢献したいと思っています
最後にみなさんに想像の種を一つ
南海トラフ巨大地震発生です
その時あなたは
皆さんは地震なんかで絶対に知らないでください
これで私の話を終わりますありがとうございました